hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to you
know what is it about sports movies
they're rarely good and yet we always
seem to enjoy watching them why it's
like watching a tape recording of a
baseball game we all know what's gonna
happen in the end so why do we waste our
time watching it this question has been
plaguing me for the last five minutes
and I can't take it anymore I have to
discover the secret behind the nostalgic
sports movies in the late 80s and
especially the early 90s we get a huge
flood children sports movies you could
say the start of it all was the Bad News
Bears at least that's where the formula
started you know the formula about the
underdog team of misfits who don't look
like they have a chance and then somehow
turn into the greatest team of all time
within one season it may have started
with the bad news bears but was the
Mighty Ducks that got the attention of
our generation it was about a lawyer who
had to spend his community service time
teaching peewee hockey to a bunch of
rowdy kids and as you might have guessed
hijinks ensue
of course in a matter of no time at all
the team makes it to the championship
because they start playing with heart it
wasn't a good movie but it wasn't really
a bad movie it was just kind of generic
supports beer but for some reason we all
saw it
which meant not one but two sequels
actually came out of this with the exact
same storyline but wait a minute how can
the exact same team that won the
championship suddenly need to be trained
again have you guys been training in the
off season you know I knew we forgot
something
that's very hey so this film spawned
dozens of mightyduck ripoffs including
little giants little big league little
angels in the outfield well okay maybe
they were all little but you get the
point everybody loved this formula and
abused it to death and if there's
anything these films have taught us it's
that there's a very specific type of
team you need in order to beat the
championships for example you always
need the fat kid the kid who does
nothing but apparently eat food and talk
about how much he likes eating food
after that you need the geeky kid the
kid who always over analyzes everything
and has to wear glasses so that you
automatically know that he's the geeky
kid which I highly resented and then of
course you need the girl the only single
solitary female who shows that girls can
do anything that boys can except move a
couch or pee standing up we own that and
last but not least you need the
good-looking all-star the character
who's troubled confused and could be the
best player on the team and only
somebody would give him a chance you're
up here me but I'm just an emotionally
troubled rookie what could I have to
offer you got Angie with you right now
what oh yeah apparently there's angels
out there to help players win by
cheating at baseball games at least
that's what they tell us in angels in
the outfield a film that stars an actor
that you might find to be a little
familiar okay that's right Tommy from
third Rock from the Sun stars in this
stinker as he tries to ask his father
when they'll be a family again
I'd say when the Angels win the pennant
in a last desperate attempt Tommy
actually turns to God and asks him for
help
faster than you can say religious
blasphemy tommy's visited by angels who
actually helped out the team to get them
to the pennant
now what sense does that make are you
seriously telling me God is up into
heaven somewhere saying a nasty
earthquake kills billions sorry not
really my department Oh
thousands of children starving in Africa
salary I do work in mysterious ways who
a little boy wants me to rig a baseball
game so he could be reunited with this
selfish jackass father who don't hey you
stop that curveball you help this
pitching you give him a backrub you get
that DiPietro that looks like
Christopher like to do some pointless
flashy special effects my god I've never
seen a cause more worthy but not all
sports movies necessarily have to follow
a team like how about the Karate Kid you
remember the kid that actually learns
karate by painting fences and waxing
cars yeah I know this sounds a complete
bullshit but I believe in this method so
much so that I have been training for
weeks painting my fences and waxing my
cars to become the ultimate karate
master and now I think it's time to put
my newly founded teachings to the test
this is my opponent and now I will
demonstrate the brute fighting force
that I have become
okay so maybe the idea is a little
far-fetched but not as far-fetched as
some of the other underdog stories where
the start of the movie is literally an
underdog like in Air Bud yeah you
remember this piece of shit right the
movie about a dog who is actually
allowed to play basketball and what
universe is this oh of course
it doesn't say in the rule book that I
can't bring a dog in to play basketball
what was I thinking and you wanna know
what else I'm pretty sure that doesn't
say anywhere that I can't bring
rollerskating black bears in it either
or how about professionally-trained tap
dancing orangutan or how about a giant
urinating elephant with one testicle who
can sing the classical works of Andrew
Lloyd Webber is that in the rule book is
it is it it is holy shit how amazingly
specific another film is just dealing
with one player is Rookie of the Year in
this film the kid injures his arm so
that it can propel back and watch like a
cowboy so a baseball team actually
decides to pick him up as a pitcher
seriously what baseball team could be so
desperate that they actually get a child
to pitch from it you sure this isn't a
true story
another reoccurring theme you might have
noticed in these movies is the villain
somehow the other team is always made up
of the most evil diabolically sneaky
bunch of people you've ever seen in your
life like remember the martial arts
teacher from the Karate Kid
this guy makes general now look like a
princess what are you here for old man
enemy deserves no mercy we looking at
what karate teacher actually talks like
this this is a karate dojo not a
knitting class well I expected this
country man from the YMCA but not from
this establishment my favorite scene is
when mr. Miyagi asked the teacher to
leave Daniel alone before the tournament
you're a pushy little bastard ain't you
I like yes yes very clever old man the
ball is in your court now but after the
tournament is over it is I will possess
the golden trophy making me sit next to
the Walgreens drugstores
god I need a girlfriend or how about the
kids from Little Giants remember how
intimidating they were we just can't buy
to tell you guys how incredibly sorry we
are that you didn't make the team oh
well thank you very much you know maybe
I had you guys paint wrong I always
assumed you were harsh mean individuals
but now I see you're just the playful
type who don't really want to hurt
anybody's feelings not dad no witty
repartee you know there's no way I can
talk my way out of than that clause it's
foolproof but I think my favorite
villains have to go to the Germans from
Cool Runnings
I don't know why but I just love these
guys they're like the great school
bullies of bobsledding why don't you put
some training views on that stick you
want to say something Jamaica come on to
make up you have no business here to
make them yeah and your father Baz of
the English needs oh no seriously
these guys are like the Nelsons of
Winter Olympics and of course you can't
have a kid sports movies without the
always popular sports montage this is
where you see a team working really hard
in a couple of clips and then suddenly
they become professional players
news flash guys fast editing and a
horrible 80s song doesn't make you
supports legends but to be honest not
all children's sports movies are
god-awful
I mean runnings isn't all that bad and
the Sandlot in my opinion is an
all-american classic but these films are
few and far between as most of these
movies just succumb to the same idiotic
cliches that make us all wanna get hit
in the head with a curveball so why do
we watch them so much because we love
sports and we always love the underdog
so much so that these films actually
continue to follow us now instead of
making cheesy sports films for kids
they're making cheesy sports films for
adults and again the good ones are few
and far between but I guess it's
important to remember that it's not how
good or bad the movie is it's how you
play the game and of course no
children's sports movie will be complete
without the latest cliche of all and so
- this cliche I say
[Music]
- Lukas - Cool Runnings
to worry
[Music]
you perfected the slope
either this times you Critic I remember
it so you don't have to